what is self-supervised learning and why
is it the dark matter of intelligence
i'll start by the dark matter part
uh
there is obviously a kind of learning
that humans and animals are
are doing that we currently are not
reproducing properly with machines with
ai right so the most popular approaches
to machine learning today are
or paradigms i should say are supervised
running and reinforcement learning
and they are extremely inefficient
supervised learning requires many
samples for learning anything
and reinforcement learning requires a
ridiculously large number of
trials and errors to for you know a
system to run anything
um
and that's why we don't have
self-driving cars
that's a big leap from one to the other
okay so that to solve difficult problems
you have to have a lot of uh human
annotation for supervised learning to
work and to solve those difficult
problems with reinforcement learning you
have to have
some way to maybe simulate that problem
such that you can do that large scale
kind of learning that reinforcement
learning requires right so how is it
that you know most teenagers can learn
to drive a car in about 20 hours of
practice
whereas
even with millions of hours of
simulated practice a self-driving car
can't actually learn to drive itself
properly
um and so obviously we're missing
something right and it's quite obvious
for a lot of people that
you know the immediate response you get
from
many people is well you know humans use
their background knowledge
to learn faster and they're right
now how was that background knowledge
acquired and that's the big question
so now you have to ask
you know how do
babies in the first few months of life
learn how the world works
mostly by observation because they can
hardly act in the world
and they learn an enormous amount of
background knowledge about the world
that may be the
the basis of what we call common sense
this type of learning is not learning a
task it's not
being reinforced for anything it's just
observing the world and figuring out how
it works
building world models learning world
models
how do we do this and how do we
reproduce this in in machines so cell
supervision learning
is
you know one
instance of one attempt at trying to
reproduce this kind of learning
okay so
you're looking at just observation so
not even the interacting part of a child
it's just sitting there watching mom and
dad walk around pick up stuff
all of that that's that's what you mean
by background knowledge perhaps not even
watching mom and dad just you know
watching the world go by
just having eyes open or having eyes
closed or the very act of opening and
closing eyes
that the world appears and disappears
all that basic information
and you're saying in in order to learn
to drive
like the reason humans are able to learn
to drive quickly some faster than others
is because of the background knowledge
they were able to watch cars operate in
the world
in the many years leading up to it the
physics of basics objects all that kind
of stuff that's right i mean the basic
physics of objects you don't even know
you don't even need to know you know how
a car works right because that you can
learn fairly quickly i mean the example
i use very often is you're driving next
to a cliff
and you know in advance because of your
you know understanding of intuitive
physics that if you turn the wheel to
the right the car will veer to the right
will run off the cliff
fall off the cliff and nothing good will
come out of this right
um but if you are a sort of
you know tabularized reinforcement
learning system that doesn't have a
model of the world
you have to repeat falling off this
cliff thousands of times before you
figure out it's a bad idea and then a
few more thousand times before you
figure out how to not do it and then a
few more million times before you figure
out how to not do it in every situation
you ever encounter
so self-supervised learning still has to
have
some source of truth
being told to it by somebody and it's so
you have to figure out a way without
human
assistance or without significant amount
of human assistance to get that truth
from the world
so the mystery there is um
how much signal is there how much truth
is there that the world gives you
whether it's the human world
like you watch youtube or something like
that or it's the more natural world
so how much signal is there
so here's the trick there is way more
signal
in sort of a self-supervised setting
than there is in either supervised or
reinforcement setting
and this is going to my you know analogy
of the cake
the you know low cake as someone has
called it where
when you try to figure out how much
information you ask the machine to
predict and how much feedback you give
the machine at every trial
in reinforcement learning you give the
machine a single scaler you tell the
machine you did good you did bad and you
you and you only
tell this to the machine once in a while
when i say you it could be the the
universe telling the machine right
um
but it's just one scalar so as a
consequence there is you you cannot
possibly learn something very
complicated without many many many
trials where you get many many feedbacks
of this type
supervised running you you give a few
bits to the machine
at every every sample
let's say you're training a
system on you know recognizing images on
imagenet there is 1000 categories that a
little less than 10 bits of information
per sample
but star supervisor here is the setting
you
ideally we don't know how to do this yet
but ideally you would
show a machine a segment of
a video and then stop the video and ask
me ask the machine to predict what's
going to happen next
and so you let the machine predict and
then you let time
go by and show the machine what actually
happened and hope the machine will you
know learn to do a better job at
predicting next time around there's a
huge amount of information you give the
machine because it's an entire video
clip
of uh you know of the future after the
video clip you fed it
in the first place so both for language
and for vision
there's a
subtle seemingly trivial construction
but maybe that's representative of what
is required to create intelligence which
is
filling the gap
so the gaps
it sounds dumb but can you
it's
it is possible you can solve all of
intelligence in this way just for both
language
just
give a sentence
and continue it or give a sentence and
there's a gap in it uh
some words blanked out and you fill in
what words go there
for vision
you give a sequence of images
and predict what's going to happen next
or you fill in what happened in between
do you think it's possible that
formulation alone
as a signal for self-supervised learning
can solve intelligence for vision and
language i think that's our best shot at
the moment um so whether this will
take us all the way to you know
human-level intelligence or something or
just cat-level intelligence
uh it's not clear but
among all the possible approaches that
people have proposed i think it's our
best shot so
i think this idea of uh
an intelligent system filling in the
blanks either
you know predicting the future inferring
the past
filling in missing information
uh you know i'm currently filling the
blank of what is behind your head and
what you what your head looks like and
you know from from the back uh because i
have you know basic knowledge about how
humans are made and i don't know if
you're gonna you know where you're gonna
say which point you're gonna speak
whether you're gonna move your head this
way or that way which way you're gonna
look but i know you're not gonna just
de-materialize and reappear three meters
uh
down the hall uh you know because i know
what's possible and what's impossible uh
according to into the physics so you
have a model of what's possible what's
impossible and then you'd be very
surprised if it happens and then you'll
have to reconstruct your model
right so that that's the model of the
world it's what tells you you know what
fills in the blanks so given your
partial information about the state of
the world given by your perception uh
your your model of the world fills in
the missing information and that
includes predicting the future
retrodicting the past uh you know
filling in things you don't immediately
perceive and that doesn't have to be
purely
generic vision or visual information or
generic language you can go to specifics
like uh
predicting
what control decision you make when
you're driving in a lane you have a
sequence of images from a vehicle and
then you could
you have information if you recorded on
video where the car ended up going so
you can go back in time and predict what
the car went based on the visual
information that's very specific domain
specific right but the question is
whether we can come up with sort of a
generic
method
for
you know training machines to do this
kind of prediction or filling in the
blanks so right now
uh this type of approach has been
unbelievably successful in the context
of natural language processing uh every
modern natural language processing is
pre-trained in self-supervised manner
to fill in the blanks to you you show it
a sequence of words you remove 10
percent of them and then you train some
gigantic neural net to predict the words
that are missing
that and once you've pre-trained that
network you can use the
internal representation learn by it as
input to
you know
something that you train supervised or
whatever
that's been incredibly successful not so
successful in images although it's
making progress
and uh and it's based on uh sort of
manual data augmentation
we can go into this later but what has
not been successful yet is training for
video so getting a machine to learn to
represent the visual world for example
by just watching video nobody has really
succeeded in doing this
you